abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
daha
sonra
gerçeği Fort edip önce
çok kolay
çünkü bazı kelimeler sadece kelime değil
arkasında o kadar büyük kavramlar ve o
kavramlardan çıkartabilecek o kadar
uygulamalarını deyip gerçeklik gitmesi
gerçekten bunlardan bir tanesi
Çünkü biz o
[Müzik]
ne
yaptı bir şey Arkadaşlarınızı öyle
söyleyeyim Daha değil insanın kendini
bilmesi Bilmiyorum benim açımdan
teması şeker atıyoruz
biliyorsunuz
daha mi
[Müzik]
o diyarda Çocuğum daha sonradan sularını
yaptığı çalışmaları yüzünden modelimizi
ama sizinkilerden bir tane Siz burada
duruyorsunuz başka bir
şey yok Sadece o
[Müzik]
İyi
tamam ya düşünürdüm bir şey yok biraz
diye giden yok yani gerçekliği babası ve
sakin bir şeyler var çünkü
açısından
gerçek mi
[Müzik]
ki
Selamın değil mi uzaklaştığı zaman
bunların arasındaki kuvvet değişiyor ama
bunları arasında nasıl bir haberleşme
Bak yazıyor O
[Müzik]
Bu bir sorun Her şey istemeyeceğim kabul
edilebilir olması lazım yaptıklarımızdan
gözlemlerimiz için Nihayet her zaman
yaptığımız bütün çalışmalarda
oluşturduğumuz bütün modellerde her
zaman olacak
fiziksel gerçekleştirecek
Selam
bugün önemli değil şey bu gerçeklik
kavramı Doğa yasaları açısından da eğer
bakarsanız gerçeklik kavramını bunların
değişebilir oldu
yanlışlanabilir olmak bilimsel kuramlar
için çok önemli bir şey geldi Arkadaşlar
mesela söyleyebilirim dünya Biz dur bu o
[Müzik]
en uzun uçları dünyanın en öne çekelim
tekrar
gösteriyorum yani şekilli olduğu
anlayabiliriz ama bir şey söylemiyor
Dünya kendi etrafında döndüm Çünkü gözle
görülmeyen varlıklar olduğu diyor bu
doğru doğru
olabilir o o
[Müzik]
bu Google'ın olduğum her zaman anlamını
verildi bir engelle diyorum gene basit
bir sonuç olur doğada kaç tane elektrik
gidiyor
257 gider nedir Biz olduğunda
doğru cevap şu
ana kadar yaptığımız
[Müzik]
olması Varsa at
bu
şurada gördüğünüz gibi 63 okuyamadım
yani o Gerçek değil doğasının En Son
hali son halimizin Ondan emin olabilir
miyim fiziksel olarak hayır
O bizim Çünkü dediğim gibi söylediğim
şeyler de bütün oluşturduğumuz
modellerde sınıf ne kadar olursa olur
bugüne kadar yaptığımız bütün
gözlemeleri doğru bir şekilde kusursuz
bir şekilde açılıyor de olsa her kuralım
mı
o benim açımdan bir temelinde
dışarısında Biz gerçeklik deyince doğa
yasalarını ve bunların doğasının Aslında
anlamaya çalışıyoruz Bu ısırdığını
görmek çalışıyoruz
O
nasıl oluyor birkaç kişi var bir tanesi
bazen önceden gözlemle Bazı şeylerin
farkına varıyor
mesela geçtiğimiz yüzyılda
hayatımıza
yaptıkları gözlemledim Hepsi O da
çok iyi gözlemlerde ama o
[Müzik]
Bu
nasıl açıklayacağımız alacak bir
matematiksel formülasyon geliştirdim
sonra
ne
olduğunu anlamaya kullanırız yine
korkuteli'nden örnekleri günümüze
bilgisayarlar ya da buna benzer şeyler
oluşturulmasında
önemli unsurlardan bir tanesi sizin
bildiğiniz bilgisayar sistemlerini
kavramı başlangıçta geceler bir tanem
siz kova bu dizide adına donanımlı
denilen bir şey de bir şey de
[Müzik]
ya bildiğiniz bilgisayarlardaki
şifreleme saatte bir şeyleri Aslında çok
radikal olarak değiştirip erkek çizme
önce sistemler olursanız alacağım
olabilirsiniz başka bir o
[Müzik]
oy
kullanır bizim çok şükür teknoloji
olacak şimdi hem güvenlik hırsızdan
oraya kaç alırsınız Bir de bazen
Buradaki gibi
göreceğimizi elimizde oluşturduğumuz
model önce senin olabilir mesela Arslan
programı 1915'de orta yaptı bu kurumun
içinde Aslında kullanıp ortaya atıldığı
dönemde kuramı oluşturan o
[Müzik]
Bak şimdi sana bir şey etrafındaki
Kürtlerin oluşturduğu desem bu desen
üzere Burası üzerinde Şunların hepsini
kalınlığını Ya da buradaki bölgenin
alanını ne kadar oluyordu oradaki ton
farklılığı mesaj bir şeylerin hepsi
bizim kurallarımızı tipi çekip
kurallarınızı tespit ettiğiniz şeyler
Burası sadece birisidir görünüyor ama
değişikliklerin sizi modellerimiz için
bir ve teşvik ediyor nasıl olduğunu
biliyoruz bu çok dediğim gibi müthiş bir
şey
uzun yıllar taşların kendisinin
oluşturduğu içerisinde bu yapalım
olmayacağım ki
[Müzik]
O
zamanı yapısı herhangi biri cismin o
uzak zamanı üzerine hareket ettiği bizim
onunla ilgili oluşturduğumuz mekanizma
ve sahip ve Uçakla ya modelin sonucu
olarak ortaya çıkar o
[Müzik]
Sen beni alarak oluşturduğu görüldü Baba
bize bu şeyi gözlemlemeye çalışmakta
teknolojik açıdan çok iddalı şeyleri
Bizim sırlarımızı her geçen gün zorlayan
şeyler
Dolayısıyla bu
gerçeklik
gösterdim şeylerden dolayı mı
[Müzik]
işte bu noktada şifre Aslında bu işte
gerçek kavramının ne olduğunu bizi nasıl
anlamamız ya da görmeniz gerektiği benim
açımdan ya da temel bilimler ve
Araştırma gel ilgilenen kişiler
açısından Aslında Bize en büyük getir
Siz bu konuya mi
[Müzik]
Bu bir doktoru bu
yöntemini
kullanılması durumunda içine düşecek çok
acıktı biraz olur
bu
çevremizde gördüğümüz rahat oturmuş
orada bu hafızayı hatayı görür
gerçek doğasını anlamak bizim açımızdan
diğerlerinden
sonra o
[Müzik]
Ama
dediğim gibi bilimsel düşündüm Biz
burada ben kendim kendi bakış açına
kendi yaşam alanı da bu evleniyorum
bilimsel düşünme düşünelim önemi ile
ilgili bir şeyler söylüyorum Sonra bir
dünyada yaşıyoruz bu hayatı da
gerçekleşiyor burada bilinçsizce
tüketilen insan toplulukları arasında
gerçekten o
[Müzik]
Ben her zaman şunu benzer şeyler bulduk
Şu son yaşadığımız görevlerde sonra bir
şeyler bilirsiniz dünyanın sonu değil
dünyanın sonu gelmez Dünyada yaşayan her
zaman bir yolunu bulur ortaya çıkar
insanlığınsonu göre biz gidebiliriz
dünya bulduğumuzda Görünüşe göre
daha önce çok güzel konuşmak zaten o
[Müzik]
o İngilizce birlikte çevireceğiz
ifade çok seviyorum Muharrem'i mirası
bağlıdır
bir aile olmak lazım böyle konularda
gerçekten içselleştirerek fazla Yaşamak
lazım bizim için
Çünkü
insan olarak yaşamalı gereği
bazı konularda inançlarımız olabilir
Bunlar daha
[Müzik]
çok kolay ulaşılabilecek en azından
tanımları ve rakamları doğru yere okula
gideceğim düşünüyorum çok teşekkür
ederim ya